speaking of parties caesar's palace is
where it is at that's where anthony
bailey i love anthony he's got a very
tough job tonight oh my gosh how come i
don't have this job standing outside and
partying with the people how are you sir
nikki good evening and good evening
michael i'll tell you it is starting to
be quite a party already out here the
crowds filling in behind us there uh you
can see we've got some friends in from
the texas area there san antonio we just
got a chance to meet them a few moments
ago the strip is packed right now with
folks as far as the eye can see it's
going to be a wild night out here they
opened up to walking traffic here just a
few minutes ago and the crowds are
beginning to fill in all looking to have
a good time out here in the city of las
vegas
and bring in 2022 so you'll definitely
want to stick around with us all night
long we'll get a chance to bring you
some of the interviews the big question
is why las vegas why not other places
well people love coming back and we've
talked to some folks already that have
made this an annual thing so we'll get a
chance to share a little bit about what
they have to say and get ready for those
wonderful new year's fireworks coming up
in just a few
all right guys well hey let's talk about
what's going on here
hello how's it going happy new year how
are you guys
all right where are you where are you
guys in from from los angeles all right
so you made the trip out to l.a what is
it you love about vegas everything vegas
is just fabulous
vegas just everybody
and he's got the head gear on there two
folks are lined up up and down the
street here
it's a wild night nicki and michael is
tossing back over to you
i definitely want one of those crowns
you need a crown and i'm saying it's
starting to